écosse 242 l'europe sombre dans le chaos
au coeur d'une lutte sans merci
une femme pourrait changer le cours de
l'histoire découvrez le destin
extraordinaire de marie stuart reine aux
trois royaumes
vous devrez vous adressez à moi en tant
que reine de france d'écossé et
d'angleterre ait eu un faux nom 90 p
pose aux trois maris n'ai-je pas le
droit de choisir qui je veux et posé
toute ma vie j'ai attendu de rencontrer
un homme comme fois mère d'un futur
sauveur
véritables chefs de guerre qu'est ce
petit coquin découvrez la femme qui se
cache derrière la légende c'est
effrayant de penser que j'ai pu être la
cause d'une guerre soient pas victimes
de ta gentillesse
marie reine decosse
je ne suis qu'une pauvre femme
sans couronne son pays sans peuple
maintenant en dvd